une colonne de chars veut ce prix sous
les feux ces images tournées hier par un
drone sont diffusées par l'armée
ukrainienne
elle montre que la progression russe en
direction de la capitale se heurtent à
une vive résistance
cette colonne avait progressé rapidement
en provenance de l'est elle serait
actuellement stoppés à brovary à une
quinzaine de kilomètres de kiev
dans les airs en revanche
la supériorité totale comme ici à
jitomir une caserne était ciblé la bombe
s'est abattue sur des habitations
cet homme est en colère lui au moins il
n'aura plus besoin de la fermeture de
l'espace aérien mais nous aussi
près de kiev les évacuations se
poursuivent avec les moyens du bord
attaché sur une porte ou encore dans un
chariot ces personnes âgées étaient
prisonnières incapable de partir
d'elle-même de leur domicile les autres
plus valides continue à traverser la
rivière qui sépare irp in de la capitale
un pope orthodoxe leur donne la
bénédiction
plusieurs corridors humanitaires sont
ouverts depuis hier ils ont permis
l'évacuation de 35000 personnes un
soulagement pause bettana
notre maison est détruite on a vécu dans
la cave pendant 14 jours sans lumière ni
eau ni chauffage mais on reviendra chez
nous j'en suis sûr au point de rencontre
elle retrouve sa fille
quand tu es vivante amour de ma vie à la
joie des retrouvailles se mêlent
l'inquiétude pour le futur restait à
kiev au risque de subir de nouveaux
bombardements ou partir encore plus loin